brace yourself because everything you're
about to see is
total horseshit
get it get it cat
[Music]
the coronavirus you know the thing you
have to regularly convince your parents
still exists oh you went to a shonies
did you
who else was there the whole town wow
please stay inside you extremely fragile
maniacs
the john oliver memorial sewer plant
because it's full of just like you john
i want this magnificent piece of rat
erotica which
someone bought in 1992 there's no chance
right
we did it
very nice indeed i think aviator glasses
should only be worn by hot pilots
cute babies and cute baby pilots
choke slammed me to hell you nasty shed
dislocate my
ankles slap a restraining order on me
you forlorn
oh you should be ashamed of
yourself
because you know this was inappropriate
right but just from the beginning
you were just like what i was having
some weird fun
exactly yeah and now you're what i'm
america's naughtiest
[Applause]
i believe i have something you're
looking for world
and it's called hope
the best is yet to come
okay then let tomorrow be about
solutions
today is about vengeance
[Music]
you